necesitan pasar cinco etapas de crecimiento:
Primero, la sociedad tradicional, donde la producción nacional está limitada
por su tecnología, sus instituciones y su mentalidad;
luego están las condiciones previas al impuso inicial,
donde comienza la industria bancaria,
la mecanización del trabajo y la creencia
de que el crecimiento es necesario para algo más que crecer,
como para conseguir dignidad nacional o una vida mejor para los niños;
luego, el impulso inicial, donde el interés compuesto
está integrado en las instituciones económicas
y el crecimiento se convierte en la condición normal;
cuarto, la marcha hacia la madurez
donde pueden tener cualquier industria, sin importar
su base de recursos naturales;
y la quinta y última etapa, la era del alto consumo masivo
donde pueden comprar todos los bienes de consumo que deseen,
como bicicletas y máquinas de coser...
esto fue en 1960, recuerden.
Bueno, la metáfora del avión está implícita en esta historia,
pero este avión no es como ningún otro,
ya que nunca se le permite aterrizar.
Rostow nos dejó volando en el ocaso del consumismo masivo,
y él lo sabía.
Como escribió:
"Y luego la pregunta más allá,
donde la historia solo nos ofrece fragmentos:
"¿Qué hacer cuando el aumento del ingreso real
pierde su propio encanto?"
Él hizo esa pregunta, pero nunca la respondió, y esta es la razón.
Era 1960,
él era asesor del candidato a la presidencia John F. Kennedy,
que se postulaba para las elecciones con una promesa de crecimiento del 5 %,
así que el trabajo de Rostow era mantener ese avión volando,
no preguntar si, cómo o cuándo se le permitiría aterrizar.
Así que aquí estamos, volando hacia el ocaso del consumismo masivo
más de medio siglo después,
con economías que han llegado a esperar, exigir y depender
de un crecimiento interminable,
porque somos financiera, política y socialmente adictos a esto.
Financieramente adictos al crecimiento, porque el sistema financiero actual
está diseñado para perseguir la tasa más alta de rendimiento monetario,
poniendo a las empresas que cotizan en bolsa bajo una presión constante
por aumentar sus ventas,
aumentar sus cuotas de mercado y sus ganancias,
y porque los bancos crean dinero como deuda que genera intereses,
que debe ser pagado con más dinero.
Políticamente adictos al crecimiento
porque los políticos quieren subir los ingresos fiscales sin subir impuestos
y un PIB creciente parece una forma segura de hacerlo.
Y ningún político quiere perder su lugar en la foto familiar del G-20.
(Risas)
Pero si su economía deja de crecer mientras las demás siguen avanzando,
bueno, serán expulsados por la próxima potencia emergente.
Y somos socialmente adictos al crecimiento,
porque gracias a un siglo de propaganda del consumidor,
que fue fascinantemente creada por Edward Bernays,
el sobrino de Sigmund Freud,
que se dio cuenta de que la psicoterapia de su tío
podría convertirse en una terapia minorista muy lucrativa
si pudieran convencernos para que creamos
que hay una transformación en nosotros cada vez que compramos algo más.
Ninguna de estas adicciones son infranqueables,
pero todas merecen mucha más atención de lo que reciben actualmente,
porque miren hacia dónde nos ha estado llevando este viaje.
El PIB global es 10 veces más grande de lo que era en 1950
y ese aumento ha traído prosperidad a miles de millones de personas,
pero la economía global también se ha vuelto increíblemente divisiva,
con grandes cuotas de rendimiento a la riqueza
acumulando ahora una fracción del uno % global.
Y la economía se ha vuelto increíblemente degenerativa,
desestabilizando rápidamente este planeta delicadamente equilibrado
sobre el que dependen nuestras vidas.
Nuestros políticos lo saben, y le brindan nuevos destinos al crecimiento.
Pueden tener crecimiento ecológico, inclusivo,
crecimiento inteligente, resistente y equilibrado.
Elijan cualquier futuro que desee siempre que elijan crecimiento.
Creo que es hora de elegir una ambición más alta, una mucho más grande,
porque el desafío del siglo XXI para la humanidad es claro:
satisfacer las necesidades de todas las personas
con los medios disponibles de este planeta extraordinario, único y vivo
para que nosotros y el resto de la naturaleza podamos prosperar.
El progreso en este objetivo no va a ser medido con la métrica de dinero.
Necesitamos un panel de indicadores.
Y cuando nos sentemos para intentar dibujar una imagen que lo represente,
aunque suene extraño,
aparecerá como una rosquilla.
Lo sé, lo siento,
pero déjenme presentarles a la única rosquilla
que podría realmente ser buena para nosotros.
Imaginen usar los recursos de la humanidad irradiando desde el centro.
En ese agujero en el medio están las personas que no alcanzan
las necesidades vitales.
No tienen comida, atención médica, educación, voz política, vivienda
que toda persona necesita para una vida de dignidad y oportunidad.
Queremos sacarlos a todos de ese agujero, con una base social
dentro de esa misma rosquilla ecológica.
Pero, y es un gran pero,
no podemos permitir que el uso colectivo de recursos rebase ese círculo exterior,
el techo ecológico,
porque pusimos tanta presión en este extraordinario planeta
que comenzamos a ponerlo patas arriba.
Causamos degradación del clima, acidificamos los océanos,
un agujero en la capa de ozono,
empujar más allá de los límites planetarios
de los sistemas de apoyo vital que tienen por lo menos 11 000 años
hizo de la tierra un hogar benevolente para la humanidad.
Así este desafío doble de satisfacer nuestras necesidades
dentro de los medios del planeta,
invita a una nueva forma de progreso,
ya no es esta línea de crecimiento en constante aumento,
sino un punto dulce para la humanidad,
prosperando en equilibrio dinámico entre la base y el techo.
Realmente me impresioné cuando dibujé esta imagen
al comprender que el símbolo del bienestar en muchas culturas antiguas
refleja este mismo sentido de equilibrio dinámico,
desde los maoríes takarangi
al yin yang taoísta, el nudo infinito budista,
la doble espiral celta.
Entonces, ¿podemos encontrar este equilibrio dinámico en el siglo XXI?
Bueno, esa es una pregunta clave,
porque como muestran estas cuñas rojas,
ahora mismo estamos lejos del equilibrio,
quedándonos cortos y excediéndonos al mismo tiempo.
Si miran ese agujero, pueden ver
que millones o miles de millones de personas
en todo el mundo están todavía por debajo de sus necesidades más básicas.
Sin embargo, ya hemos sobrepasado al menos cuatro de estos límites planetarios,
arriesgándonos a un impacto irreversible de este colapso climático
y de este colapso del ecosistema.
Este es el estado de la humanidad y de nuestro hogar planetario.
Nosotros, la gente de principios del siglo XXI,
esta es nuestra selfie.
Ningún economista del siglo pasado vio esta imagen,
Entonces, ¿por qué imaginamos que sus teorías
están a la altura de asumir sus desafíos?
Necesitamos nuestras propias ideas,
porque somos la primera generación que ve esto
y puede que la ultima con una oportunidad real de darle vuelta a esta historia.
Ya ven, según la economía del siglo XX si el crecimiento crea desigualdad,
no traten de redistribuirla,
porque este crecimiento volverá a arreglar las cosas.
Si el crecimiento crea contaminación, no intenten regularlo,
porque este crecimiento limpiará las cosas de nuevo.
Excepto, que resulta que no lo hace,
y no lo hará.
Necesitamos crear economías que aborden este déficit y rebasamiento juntos,
a través del diseño.
Necesitamos economías regenerativas y distributivas por diseño.
Ya ven, hemos heredado industrias degenerativas.
Tomamos los materiales de la tierra, los convertimos en lo que queremos,
los usamos por un tiempo, a veces solo una vez, y luego los tiramos,
y eso nos está llevando al extremo de los límites planetarios,
Así que tenemos que girar esas flechas,
crear economías que trabajen con y dentro de los ciclos del mundo viviente,
para que los recursos nunca se agoten sino que se usen una y otra vez,
economías que funcionen con luz solar,
donde el residuo de un proceso sea el alimento del próximo.
Y este tipo de diseño regenerativo está surgiendo por todas partes.
Más de cien ciudades por todo el mundo, de Quito a Oslo,
de Harare a Hobart,
ya generan más del 70 % de su electricidad
del sol, el viento y las olas.
Ciudades como Londres, Glasgow, Ámsterdam
son pioneros en el diseño circular de la ciudad,
hallando formas de convertir los residuos de un proceso urbano
en alimento para el siguiente.
Y desde Tigray, Etiopía hasta Queensland, Australia,
agricultores y silvicultores están regenerando
paisajes antes estériles para que rebosen de vida nuevamente.
Pero además de ser regenerativas por diseño,
nuestras economías deben ser distributivas por diseño,
y tenemos oportunidades sin precedentes para que eso suceda,
porque las tecnologías centralizadas del siglo XX, las instituciones.
concentraban la riqueza, el conocimiento y el poder en pocas manos.
Este siglo, podemos diseñar nuestras tecnologías e instituciones
para que distribuyan riqueza, conocimiento y empoderamiento a muchos.
En vez de energía de combustibles fósiles y fabricación a gran escala,
tenemos redes de energía renovable, plataformas digitales e impresión 3D.
200 años de control corporativo de la propiedad intelectual
se han cambiando por un conocimiento global entre iguales
de código abierto, y de enfoque ascendente.
Y corporaciones que aún persiguen La tasa máxima de rendimiento
para sus accionistas,
de repente parecen bastante desactualizados
al lado de las empresas sociales que están diseñadas para generar
múltiples formas de valorar y compartir con aquellos a través de sus redes.
Si podemos aprovechar las tecnologías actuales,
desde la IA hasta blockchain
al Internet de las cosas, a la ciencia material,
si podemos aprovechar estos al servicio del diseño distributivo,
podemos asegurar que la atención de salud, la educación,
finanzas, energía, voz política
alcancen y empoderen a esas personas que más lo necesitan.
Ya ven, el diseño regenerativo y distributivo
crea oportunidades extraordinarias para la economía del siglo XXI.
Entonces, ¿dónde deja esto el viaje en avión de Rostow?
Bueno, algunos todavía esperan un crecimiento ecológico infinito,
la idea de que gracias a la desmaterialización,
el crecimiento exponencial del PIB puede durar para siempre
mientras que el uso de recursos sigue cayendo.
Pero miren los datos. Este es un vuelo de fantasía.
Sí, necesitamos desmaterializar nuestras economías,
pero esta dependencia en un crecimiento infinito
no puede ir separada del uso de los recursos
o de lo que sea que la escala requiera
para que nos mantenga de forma segura dentro de los límites planetarios.
Sé que esta forma de pensar sobre el crecimiento no es familiar,
porque el crecimiento es bueno, ¿no?
Queremos que nuestros hijos crezcan, nuestros jardines crezcan
Sí, mirar la naturaleza y el crecimiento
es una fuente de vida maravillosa y saludable.
Es una fase, pero muchas economías como Etiopía y Nepal hoy
pueden estar en esa fase.
Sus economías están creciendo al 7 % al año.
Pero miren de nuevo la naturaleza,
porque desde los pies de sus hijos hasta la selva amazónica,
nada en la naturaleza crece por siempre.
Las cosas crecen, y crecen y maduran,
y es solo al hacerlo que pueden prosperar durante mucho tiempo.
Ya sabemos esto.
Si les dijera que mi amiga fue al médico
que le dijo que tenía un crecimiento
que parecía muy diferente,
porque intuitivamente entendemos que si algo intenta crecer para siempre
dentro de un sistema saludable, vivo y próspero,
es una amenaza para la salud del conjunto.
Entonces, ¿por qué pensamos que nuestras economías
serían el único sistema que podría vencer esta tendencia
y tener éxito al crecer para siempre?
Necesitamos urgentemente innovaciones financieras, políticas y sociales
que permitan superar esta dependencia estructural del crecimiento,
para que podamos en su lugar enfocarnos en prosperar y mantenernos
dentro de los límites sociales y ecológicos de la rosquilla.
Y si la mera idea de los límites les hace sentir, bueno, limitados,
piensen otra vez.
Porque las personas más ingeniosas del mundo
convierten los límites en la fuente de su creatividad.
Desde Mozart con su piano de cinco octavas
Jimi Hendrix con su guitarra de seis cuerdas,
Serena Williams en una cancha de tenis.
Son los límites los que desatan nuestro potencial.
Y los límites de la rosquilla dan rienda suelta
al potencial de la humanidad
para prosperar con creatividad ilimitada, participación, pertenencia y significado.
Vamos a necesitar todo el ingenio que tenemos para conseguirlo,
así que tráiganlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)